Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to dream Daddy. Now we just are starting the new Day
Full of opportunities to make as many mistakes as we could ever hope, and hopefully meet some new dreamy daddies along the way
Anyway. Morning sleepyhead. Five more minutes.
You have never ever let me have five more minutes so get up. Finee. Goddddd.
Ugh. We have cereal for breakfast and spend the morning putting together. Amanda is much better at interpreting the tiny manuals
We're able to go together a few shelves and one desk, but I'm pretty sure it was supposed to be a bookcase
So, you excited for the cookout today? Oh
Excited to beef up my grilling skills
Yeah
I'll see this is a learning opportunity, if I can snake some hot grill tips
I think we can consider it a success. Hahaha. Don't you want to meet some of the other people in the neighborhood?
I'll Probably end up standing uncomfortably in the corner with a plate of food and hope that nobody talks to me.
Dad, you're a beautiful work in progress. We will get that butterfly to emerge from the cocoon
The Social Butterfly. Well we better start getting ready.
We definitely don't want to be late. What, no? We have to be fashionably late. Who shows up to cook out on time?
You know what, we're going early, just because you said that.
I head out the door and Amanda reluctantly follows. We walk across the street to Joseph's house with a store-bought veggie plate.
I'm a terrible cook if it doesn't involve a grill.
I guess we're not as early as we thought. Joseph's backyard is already packed with people and the smell of hot dogs wafts through the air.
Small children run through a Sprinkler and adults chat in a small cluster
I sat our veggie plate down on a table next to two other veggie plates. Huh.
Hey, it's Joseph. I wave to get his attention, the moment he sees us he jogs over, arms open wide.
Welcome! I'm so glad you two are here.
And you brought veggies!
Let me introduce you to my family. Kids, come on over here.
This is Chris, my eldest.
Hi.
This is Christian and Christie. They're twins.
They stare creepily and say nothing. All righty then.
Then of course there's our youngest, Crish.
Wait, where's Crish? Maybe Mary put him in his crib.
Oh no, it's the woman from the bar last night. What's she doing here?
Oh, and how could I forget my lovely wife Mary.
Hey.
Joseph pecks her on the cheek, she smiles.
Ah, Mary, sweetheart, did you put Crish to bed?
I'll have to go look for him.
What? You'll have to?
Joseph takes a moment to regain its composure.
Mary, this is our new neighbour, Mark, and his daughter, Amanda.
Oh, I'd shake your hand but I have a glass of wine that I need to attend to
I love her!
Nice to, ah, meet you, Mary. For the first time.
Charmed. Well, I have to go over there now. Mary leaves. Oh god this is so awkward.
I wonder if Joseph knows or if Mary knows that Joseph knows or if Joseph knows that Mary's knows that I know.
It takes all my energy not to run away from the barbecue and start afresh in a new city.
Hahaha! My wife has a wonderful sense of humor, but please you two enjoy the barbecue.
All the guys are really excited to meet you.
Wow, I think I've actually met everybody else. Oh. great. I bet you're excited to get to know everyone better
Hope you both enjoy yourselves.
Amanda and I mill around and try some of the food spread out on table.
I pick out some deviled eggs, Amanda grabs a small paper plate and immediately begins piling it with baked goods.
I don't want to have to make new friends. Come on Dad,who are you gonna party with when I go off to school?
But I don't wanna have to do the pleasantries.
Daaaaaad
Ugh. They're gonna talk about weather.
Oh, go do it make a friend. But how could I abandon my only child at a social function? That's bad parenting.
This plate of cookies is my new Dad. Bye.
Amanda shoved me into the centre of the yard. Well...
Here goes nothing. I look around the party and am surprised to see some familiar faces.
Hey! The Parties here!
Hey, I don't remember your name. Is that the barista from the coffee spoon? Oh, dang Roberts here
Oh, God. He's so handsome and brooding and dark. Oh.
Didn't that guy throw a frisbee at my head?
Isn't that the guy who was throwing a fit in dead goth and beyond?
Isn't that Amanda's teacher? Hey I know Craig.
But wait a second all these people live in our cil-de-sac, that can't be right.
I  better investigate. I'm gonna tal- BURGER TIME!!
Burger time!
Burger time! And without further ado let's work some magic.
Joseph closes his eyes and takes a deep breath and gets to work. With the greatest of ease, he sent patties on the grill
Flourishing as he flips his spatula in the air. It's easily some of the best grill work I've ever seen.
Man you could flip me any day.
You guys think this is my first time in front of a grill?
He's working faster now, effortlessly tossing cheese onto patties
and perfectly grilling onions on the side. One after another the dads take notice in the crowd around Joseph to admire his masterful technique.
You probably didn't know this, Mark, but Joseph is known around here for his grillsmanship
He's un-grill-lievable.
I've tried to get on his level, but I just can't ketchup.
Hyuk, hyuk!
Lettuce keep studying. (Nice flower crown.) He's a rare quality about him.
Mustard we keep talking about this. Can't we just appreciate the artiste?
I've never him make a mis-steak.
Heh heh heh heh!
Mmm. Okay, we need to stop this is getting too...
cheesy.
Yeah, please stop.
All the children at the party boo the glorious display of puns in unison.
All right, guys. The food's ready, please form an orderly barbe-queue.
Haha!
Amanda groans. We all grab our food and hang out enjoying perfectly cooked cheeseburgers.
Man, it's so wild how all of us dads live in the same cul-de-sac.
Kinda nice, isn't it? Feels like there's a real community here, totally helps when you're just a single dad trying to raise a kid.
We're happy to have you here man.
I think you're gonna like his neighborhood a lot.
Plus Amanda seem to be getting along with a lot of the kids. If she decides to get into the babysitting game, she'll really make a killing.
Hey, why don't you add us all on dadbook. Dadbook?
Yeah, it's a great social network for dads to keep in touch with each other. We're all in it.
So if you ever need to reach out to anyone, that's the simplest way to do it.
Sorry, I'm just an old-fashioned dad. Social media goes over my head sometimes.
Don't worry, Pops! I'll help you figure it out.
The rest of the BBQ goes smoothly.
We all trade stories and drink beer as our kids play on the lawn.
Amanda breaks up a fight between Carmensita and those weird twins.
I think they wanted her soul.
Amanda and I walked back to our place as the sun sets over the neighbourhood, pretty fun party don't you think?
Man, wish I could have been playing paranormal ice road truckers.
I mean, I got a burger in me, somehow or one way or another a burger is in me, sweetie
If I can impart any sort of wisdom upon you right now, and not that this was a bad situation,
but if you're ever in an uncomfortable situation
Always look for the silver lining, the silver linings get you through to the other side. we ate rocking burg's today, and it was good.
Amen, well hey at least you met some other cool dad's, you should hit them up on Dadbook.
Maybe I will, if I ever figure out how social media works.
I have a good feeling about this place. Me too, dad.
Me too. Amanda and I arrived home with the remnants of our veggie plate. Seems like nobody was really into the cauliflower.
I love cauliflower.
Any big plans for this evening. Actually yeah, I'm going out with some friends. Oh.
Is that okay? Of course just keep me posted and be home before midnight
Mm. Got it be careful. I will
Make good choices.
Of course. You call me if you need anything,
Dad, you're not going to do the thing where you wait silently for me to come home in the living room with all the lights
turned off are you? What no I've never done that and I will never do that. I'm totally going to do that tonight.
Do you have plans tonight?
I uh
I'm gonna sit in the living room with all the lights off waiting for you to come home, with a shotgun in my lap.
My plans were going to eat ice cream and watch TV with Amanda, but I'll find something to do.
I'm gonna throw a party, that's me. I'm a party kinda dad.
Partiplier. That's me. I'm gonna throw a party, a real rager, all the other dad's in the neighborhood are invited.
I'll see if I can give you a spot on the list, but honestly it's looking tight.
You may just have to wait line. I know the guy at the door, I'll get in no problem. Just relaxing tonight
Have fun, okay. Great. See you later. I watch Amanda drive off into the night,I really hope she has fun.
Makes good choices, I'll be here in the dark with a shotgun
Waiting for you to come home.
I plop down in front of the TV and turn on some wine and dine
Mastermind with Celebrity chef Gavin Chapman, looks like Gavin's making a roasted rack of lamb with rosemary
Mashed potatoes oh, it's so good. I'd love to be able to cook like that although
I think if I was actually good at cooking I use my powers for evil like just making baked
Alaska's all day instead of any food of real nutritional substance, man Gavin Chapman just caught that thing on fire.
But he meant to do it, what a professional.
I lose track of time as I blaze through several episodes of Wine and Dine Mastermind
and also one episode of some cooking show called meat hell, not even sure what that one was about.
It was just a lot of yelling. I glance at my watch, man it's almost midnight.
I should check in with Amanda. I send a text. Hey kiddo. You good?
I wander into the kitchen as I wait for a reply. Amanda's phone is almost always in her hand, so I'm sure she'll response soon, unless she's driving home in which case
I hope she doesn't respond soon because I definitely taught her than that to text and drive. I reach into the freezer and grab an ice cream sandwich.
It's a little late for this, but I think I earned it after a long day of
socialising
I check my watch again, and then my phone. Nothing yet.
Okay, see now I'm worried, do I call her? Do I call the cops? no. No. Too soon for that.
I'll just send her a gentle reminder text with a picture of me in the dark with my shotgun
What's up?
Hey, how's it going? Half an hour passes.
Now I'm really worried. The episodes of Gavin Chapman's Meat
Hell are not the only thing that's waging my anxiety, possibly exacerbating it with all the yelling
So I keep pacing around the house waiting for her to come back.
Why didn't I find out where she was going? Who is she even with? Was it that Neil fella? Why don't I have any
of her friends phone numbers? Why don't I even know her friends full names?
WHO IS EMMA P??? I decide to send her another text. Amanda,
Please text me and let me know you're okay. I can't help but think of all the awful things that could have happened to her.
Oh thank god, it's her. Amanda opens the door and shuffles in. Finally, finally she's back home. Sup. Sweetie, Thank God. You're safe
Yep
Now that I know she's okay. I'm really mad. Why didn't you answer my texts Amanda pulls her phone out of her pocket?
Oh whoops guess I didn't see those. She starts to walk to her room. Amanda Anne.
Woah, we're pulling out the middle name now? Amanda,
You came home an hour and a half after your curfew.
And you didn't respond to any my texts, you really freaked me out. I was about to call the cops.
Dad you're seriously overreacting you're not gonna be like this when I go off to school are you? Let's see.
I have a right to be concerned.
You're my only daughter.
Well, I can't give you a play-By-play of everything I do all the time.
I'm 18 you shouldn't even be able to give me a curfew in the first place.
I sit down on the couch and put my head in my hands. I feel very tired all of a sudden.
You really scared, just please don't do that again.
All right, I'm gonna go to bed now.
Amanda closes the door to her room and I head to mine. Geez. As I'm falling asleep one thing
She said keeps echoing in my mind. You're not gonna to be like this when I head off to school are you?
I definitely didn't sleep well last night. I brew some strong coffee and make some scrambled eggs for Amanda as a peace offering.
She eventually wanders into the kitchen. Hey
I thought about what you said last night. I should have texted you
I was gonna do it and I didn't she.  I honestly didn't even think about it, really sorry pops, I won't do it again.
well
hmmm
I trust you to make good choices.
I also, thought about it and I'll try to give you your space from here on out.
I gotta trust that you can take care of yourself. Team Iplier? Team Iplier!
Team Iplier!
Yeah, team Iplier in the house! all everyone of us, yeah all together a big family
Yeah, I'm not cool am I. Amanda gives me a hug. Want some eggs?
You know it, sprinkle some cheese on them. Already did. Bless you.
Amanda scarfs down the eggs in the time it takes me to wash the pan. All right I'm off to school.
Smell you later. Wait one more thing before you go. What's Dadbook?
It's a social media platform. Wait. What? What's a social media platform? Dad I have to go to school. Come on Amanda,
I'm an old man. I can't put together a Dadbook profile all on my own. All right,
I'll help you sound interesting on the internet.
Amanda spends the next couple of minutes setting up my profile on Dadbook, which as it turns out is a place where dad's can get together
And talk about fatherhood. All right pops. We got fill you out your profile, let's get some likes and dislikes.
I'm ready for this. Oh, on a Friday night You're most likely to? Ooh
Polish and sort my coin collection. Netflix and grill, baby. Fall asleep watching the history channel. Torment my children with Dad puns. Sink into blissful Oblivion. Sleep.
Is this a, is this a, is this a euphemism? Polish and sort my coin collection?
I don't know if that's a euphemism. Netflix and grill, baby. Fall asleep
Torment my children with Dad puns.
I'm Gonna go with the Dad puns.
Who doesn't like. If you had one thing to take with you on to a desert Island?
What would it be? Let's see. My trusty grill, a lost shaker of salt?
Haha, I get that. Castaway on DVD for instructional purposes. A boat obviously.
I don't need anything, my survivals skills have trained me for this day. Well grill. What's that gonna do for you?
You're not gonna have enough gas.
Lost shaker of salt? Whatever. You're surrounded by an ocean you can just dry out some sea, get sea salt.
Castaway on DVD, you wouldn't have a DVD player now  would you so that'd be stupid. A boat.
Oh good, you got fuel for that boat?
How are you going to get in the ocean if it's on the island, you gonna drag it out?
Oh, you're gonna do that. Oh real smart with you. Oh, is it a rowboat?
Oh, that's not gonna survive on the ocean, you didn't think this through obviously didn't think it's through. Survival skills training for this day. Don't need anything
What are your turn-ons?
Strong Dad arms, ugh. Tennis shoes with long white socks.
A well manicured lawn. Street Smarts. Top tier Grillmanship. Comfortable with crying.
That's not my turn on.. There's not my turn on guys. I'm Gonna go with strong Dad arms.
Real strong, real strong.
What did you want to be when you grew up?
Let's see
Technical writer for manuals and instructions. Salty boat Captain hell, yes.
Pro-skater who is also an astronaut. The president of space.
I wanted to be the president of space.
What's your favorite movie Genre?
War documentaries. Sean Connery's entire filmography. Anything on Laserdisc. Romantic comedies. Whatever will make you cry.
Old comedies that haven't aged well. I'm gonna go anything on laserdisc, I like that. What's your ideal date?
Napping together, doing a 1000 piece puzzle.
Eating a healthy dinner at 4 p.m.. Trying a geocache but getting hopelessly lost. Arson! Being emotionally vulnerable.
I like the idea of geocache, you just go ,you really do, you just get hopelessly lost, that sounds fun.
What do you never leave home without?
A sensible cardigan. My sick vape. My book of word jumbles and a pen. A cool knife. My cripplingly low self-esteem.
I'm gonna go with my crippling low self-Esteem? I just can't leave home without it. I spend a lot of time thinking about.
Conspiracy theories.
How proud I am of my child. Potential ends of the world.
If I'll ever be able to love myself as much as I love my grill. When I can get the next cup of coffee. Lawnmower modifications.
Oh, that's funny. Oh
I'll never be able to love myself as much as I love my grill. my grill's a euphemism!
Profile complete! See that wasn't so bad. Yeah, that was actually kind of fun.
I can totally spend all day on here just looking at people's profiles.
You should message me one of them, or more than one of them all these dad seemed pretty interesting. Okay, I promise
I'll make some friends. Amanda gives me a hug. Go get em Dad.
Welcome. Whoa. You'e got Dads. I've got Dads!
Look at all these dads. Oh.
fuck oh
I didn't want to like Craig, but I like Craig. mmm. Hugo's,
Hugo's interesting. Mat's cool.
Brian's a sweetheart. Roberts brooding but probably has a soft core. Damien's weird. Joseph, Joseph has some family
things going on there. I'm gonna go with Craig, reunite with good old Craig here. Hey Craig Craig.
Dad of three.
Business entrepreneur and fitness enthusiast. Juggling work family and fitness is a tough gig, but someones got do it. On a Friday night
most likely to get one last good cardio session in.
If you had to take something with you on a desert island what would it be? a box of energy bars. What're your turn-ons? a sub six-minute
mile
What did you want to be when you grew up? A beer pong world champion. What's your favourite movie? Buddy Cop movies forever.
Oh, hell, yeah, oh hell.
Yeah, gimme Hot Fuzz any day. What's your ideal date? Scaling a huge dangerous mountain for fun.
What do you never leave home without? An extra tube of energy gel.
Alright then. I spend a lot of time thinking about,my mile time used to be so good ,what happened?
Have I peaked? Oh God.
I've gotta read everyone else's profiles.  Hang on, wait. Avid music enthusiast.  Passionate coffee drinker.
You can find me most days selling beans juice. God.
Don't call it bean juice. Hanging out at the park with my amazing daughter. Hit me up about 80s new wave music.
Perfect cold brew, one drip at a time, baby. Fine tunes to pass the day away.
Multi-instrumentalism. A barista weirdly enough. Shit with subtitles.
Go to the animal Shelter and seriously consider adopting a cat.
Aw, if that was a dog I'd be right there with you. My headphones both in ear and over ear
just in case. Where do writing commas into the song titles come from, where did it go?
Can we all just agree that it's a bad idea? Oh.
Brian. What's good Brian. Hi, I'm Brian
I'd like to spend most of my days hanging out with my awesome daughter and thinking
of new ways to grill things. If you like fishing we'll get along.
On a Friday, see just how slowly I can cook a piece of brisket.
If you had one thing to take with you on an island, what would it be? My fishing pole, very smart.
What are your turn ons? A keen understanding of steak cuts. What did you want to be when you grew up? A fireman.
Romantic comedies. Deck-building. Ah, I used to build decks. that's literally, that was my job for two years.
What do you never leave home without? My portable fishing pole.
I spend a lot of time thinking about how my daughter is smart than I am. Aw
Cute! all right, okay, Robert. Why is he on here? When the internet gains sentience and decides to destroy us all
you know it'll use this information against us right? Friday night, make a deal in an alleyway. Have it go badly.
Who's the cop? Who's Giacomo I trust giacomo.
Was it giacomo? I don't know. If you had to take one thing, what would it be? A gun. Turn-ons.
Don't talk to me. What did you want to? Grifter.
Favourite movie genre?  Italian Neorealism. What is your idea date?Grave robbing. At least four knives. You never look really look into a rabid animals eyes.
All right fine then. Damian. How do you do, I finally decided to join this information superhighway?
Not entirely sure how this works, but I will try my best to understand.
I love long strolls through graveyards and spending time with my son, if you would ever like to chat about the latest
Victorian Fashion, the inevitability of our own demise or black cats, please send me a letter.
Friday nights, listen to true crime podcasts while I taxidermy my latest species
Oh, my newest specimens. Take one thing with you? A coffin
What are your turn-ons? pronouncing bosom correctly, bowzoom? bosom. What did you want to be when you grew up? A bat,
Favourite movie? Foreign arthouse horror.
Ideal date? Tt's night. We are at an industrial darkwave club in Berlin, the music drums to the beat of our hearts.
What do you never leave? an upside-down cross.
Spend a lot of time thinking about, mortality salience.
Okay. Hugo. Middle school teacher, high school teacher.
Writer of scholarly articles in the 18th century literature and various esteemed publications. If you're here
to tell me that my son put a cherry bomb in your trash, I know and I'm sorry. Friday Night.
Brew some strong tea and paint my miniatures. if you had to take one thing with you,
Remembrance of things past by Marcel Prost. Turn-ons. Muscles! Grew up wanting to be a movie star.
Favourite movie genre? documentaries on art history. Ideal date? Each of us read a different book on opposite sides with couch in comfortable silence.
That' sounds pretty damn good to me.
I've been doing a lot of reading lately. What do you never leave home without? My glasses, actually I forget them at home a lot.
Spend a long time thinking about, I worry that people who are against e-readers are more in love with the idea of books than
actually reading them. ohhhh.
Smart man, Smart man, Smart man Hugo Vega. All right, Joseph.
What have you got? Voted Maple Bay's number on youth minister for five years running.
Living in my hometown with my beautiful wife and our four amazing kids. If I'm not in church
you can catch me out in the open water setting sail on the seas of adventure.
I love playing guitar and crushing my kids at Candyland.
Friday night, lead the community in a fun mixer. My six string. My loving wife is your turn on. Aah, that's weird.
What did you want to be when you grew up? Ship Captain. Me, too.
What's the favorite movie genre? Feel-good movies. Ideal date? lovely night on town with my wife.
What do you never leave home without? The good book.
I can spend a lot of time thinking about how it can be a better man husband and father.
Oh, that's too good to be true. Nothing about that can be possibly right, your last name is Christianson.
I'm gonna go with Craig, Craig can Craig can, let's go craig. Hey Craig.
The only acceptable time and place for decaf coffee is never, and in the trash. Hey!
How dare you. I wonder what Craig's up to today.
I navigate to Craig's Dadbook page and type out a message.
Hey, bro, or should I say neighbor? Let's catch up like the old times. Ba da da boopie.
A couple moments pass before I hear a ding on the computer. It's a message from Craig.
Ding, bro! My man! Let's definitely hang soon! Might be a little different from our old weekend-long benders, but it'll still be fun.
Alright, we exchange a couple more messages, and he logs off to prep for the game.
I should see if Amanda wants to join me. I walked over to Amanda's room and knock on the door. Yo, Manda Panda.
I open the door and find Amanda sitting cross-legged on the floor surrounded by magazines  and newspaper clippings.
She seems to be making some sort of art piece.
Her eyes are a little puffy almost as if she'd been crying.
Hey, you alright? Oh. Yeah. I'm fine.
It just got sad because I realized that dogs are too often killed off in movies to elicit emotional reaction from the audience instead of being
given the respect that they deserve.
Alright.
Are you sure?
If there's you know anything going on I just want you to know that I'm here for you, and I'll always be here for you.
Whether you need a shoulder to cry on or a strong dad to go kick someones butt, I'm only a phone call away.
Thanks popsicle I appreciate that. But I'm fine really. I'm unconvinced but I'll stop badgering her about it.
I'm sure she'll tell me when she's ready. What you working on? Just a collage for class.
We're supposed to make a piece that represents our goals for the future. I take a closer look at her collage.
That's a lot of dogs dogs. It's most dogs yeah.
Did you need something? Craig invited us to a softball game, want to go?
Remember that one time you signed me up for softball and you bought me all the gear and then you took me for the first
game, then someone hit a ball towards me, and I ran off the field crying?
Then you hid in dugout and would scream if I tried to pick you up yeah, I remember that.
I was afraid of baseballs. I thought you were a gigantic sentient softball.
Does that mean you don't want to go? Amanda gets up and looks me dead in the eyes determined.
Finally ready to face my fears head on. Let's do this. Okay. All right then.
I make short drive out to the local softball field for a kid's softball game
It's pretty backed clamber up to the bleachers and take our seats on the top row and one see Greg anywhere
Why do the kids are crying and running off into the field?
You know that your relationship with softball is different from anyone elses relationship, right?
Not everyone does okay?
But if I don't see some Goods Crime Gonna be pretty this point
For nostalgic purposes of course not because they take Joy out of children fighting for Mine hmM
definitely
not that
Game start some kid runs off to the field I see craig by the dugout with the clipboard
His river strapped to his chest as per usual the guy in a pancake costume doing jumping jacks across a field I
Guess that's a minute Scott
We ain't reading the kids brightly colored jerseys. I see it's a maple baked flapjacks against the time wood ocelots go flapjacks
Choke up on the bat
Miranda yeah Miranda square up once you know about subtle enough to note that the balls are relatively hard despite the name
Yelling is fun the shot. It's gets arctic. Keep your eye on the ball
What's important is that your habit find them? What are you willing to sacrifice to win?
We've had a beer and we want to play
Sorry
My neighbors broad you not appreciate that array. They do
Maybe they're encouraged by exactly why seem to be Miranda's father gives me a dirty look
I shooed it back at him that adds to this is Gonna bring Miranda to division one Dad
Please don't find any other dads while we're out here
We watch a couple innings of softball. They aren't ready for the majors. Yeah, Craig's trained. It seemed pretty
Well seems like he's really good with kids Dex Dan craig is good with children
Amazing how hard they're hitting the ball no one has to run off the field crying in man is dear
You have to let it go
The opposing team is up and back. They hit a flyball on surf field tiny little girl tried to get on the ball
But misses or club and it's straightened for it see it's completely justifiable fear
Girl plops down in the grass to charge crying craig makes a plea line for her checking her forehead and comforting her until the parents
Arrived he carries her off the field as she saw that would be quite a hit
Pop fly right to the forehead for a little girl whoo
Man, it's strange to think about how this is a guy who once back flipped off a roof and into a pool while shotgunning and a beer
He's so... responsible.
God, that (unintelligible). He sounds so cool! I wish I could be half as cool as Craig!
F**k, Craig's cool!
Goddammit. The game resumes after the girl calms down a bit, and we watched couple more innings
Craig's team is crushing the other team in the ninth inning
The Ocelot seemed to have given up at this point
I see one outfielder eating a fistful of grass. A batter on the other team knocks a foul ball into the stands
I follow the trajectory and... Oh no,  it's coming right for me! No no no oh
NOOOO!
I close my eyes and brace for impact.
Did Craig save me?
Craig, save me! CRAIG!
I open my eyes and look over to see Amanda holding the softball, staring at it in amazement.
I c... I caught the ball.
You saved me.
I caught the ball! Dad, I caught the ball!
You did it, Amanda!
I faced my fears. I defeated the softball. I can do anything!
Amanda and I share a big hug.
It's a tender moment that I don't think anyone else watching really understood. I'm proud of you kiddo
The game ends, and Craig's team are declared the victors. We sit patiently as the girls line up to shake hands.
Great job, everyone!
Walk over to the dugout and congratulate Craig, who's standing talking with some of the parents.
Craig! Great work man!
Thanks been working hard all season. That's great. See paying off so proud of all my girls being butch if you met brier and hazel
Hello, hi briar. I hazel. Hey killer playing out there. Yeah, you got this rule
Thank you. Get us a twins. Huh, so which one of you is the evil one
Hazel yeah, it's me good looking out you guys ever pretend to be each other
I don't have a twin, but I think if I did I'd do that constantly yeah, I take all over math tests
I usually throw rocks and stuff and when people get mad I tell him I'm brier what?
we'll
Talk about this later. Talk about this later mark, bro. I just got a couple more oh my God
He's wearing pajama pants fuck I love
Fucking wearing goddamn fucking oh
God, aah
Sorry, I'm wearing pants today, but guys it's destiny
Greg mark, bro, then we can hang sound good
Just man one of the moms jumps into the conversation not so fast we have to celebrate our win craig
I'm taking the whole team to get people in I don't know if I can
Nonsense the girls won. What's or a celebration could we have without our fearless leader?
She lays her hand on a shoulder and give them goo-goo eyes man. This mom is laying it on thick
Man, I cheryl
All right
All right, is it cool with my bro comes along mom looks slightly put out but covers it up with a smile of course
Where we going thirsty's pizza wow? Huh? It's a real place
An endless stream of girls clad in softball gear piling a Minivan and into a local pizza Buffet
Which is actually called thirsty's pizza, then I trail behind them with Greg
Reminds me of all the awful people we put on our bodies back in the day
Remember we used to just fold up whole pies in half and then put taco fillings inside. Oh Pete tacos. I'll never forget
How do we survive college our bodies were younger back then more elastic more able to handle the toxic waste we put inside of us?
All the good old days it's running around playing arcade games and even reaching food man
And I run up a couple of slices of media creams. Give me a pizza bit. No absolutely not. I'm just kidding
I'm strictly eating salad here. Thanks for addressing the issue Amanda Dad
Different mom walks up to it talking to craig as if we weren't even there
Rag, thank you so much for looking after our kids my daughter tells me every day about how great
I'm happy to look after them. Definitely helps it I've kids in my house. It's been so hard since Daniel left
I'm glad to know that my children in their
strong
growing male Role Model
Man, I look at each other again craig gets it from all Angles. Huh Greg smile cheaper, sweetie. Thank you so much
dude
Rec holds his fist up for a fist bump from the mom and fixes a maneuver to lighten the conversation
It looks super uncomfortable. I from a bone here you see
Smokescreen Martha create a diversion tag team with Amana I created diversion
But anyway, I mean, I'm going to throw myself on to the arcade machines
But the first things come to mind what's long-haul paranormal eyes were go to read this book what?
Kalman flynt dog-bone visit a truck shop that was also a cemetery and led an exorcism of ghosts
I was hunting the hot dog grill. I know Amanda for sport
It was also a demon haunting one of the bathroom stalls, and it kept throwing poop on the wall pretty scary stuff
Actually now that I think about this good chance. It was a non paranormal explanation for that, but still quality tablets
I haven't seen that. I've seen that either. Wow. We have so much in common
She turns her back on me to talk to crack
So I'm talking taking hazel and briar tonight for the sleepover
Yep, they're pretty excited about you'll keep them out of trouble right of course, but I could always use help with
Watching after everyone tonight not doing anything
Not just laying is really going for a game. Huh, you'll actually be nice to have a night for myself and river
Thanks for the invite
Martha you might want to grab your child
She's stuffing Pete is going plot or the angrily turns our attention towards our daughter differently not another arcade machine
I swear if I have to buy it well the storms off towards her kid. She seems nice
Yeah, the team is one big weird family takes all sorts right Tiffany. Don't even be tokens Tiffany the Stellar hitter
I don't think I have time to talk to craig now and your busy guy. Huh only on days like today. Oh
Dad
Hey girls, Dad. Can you help us beat a record on DDR?
I told Ariana stab me you can destroy him on the dance mat, please help. You know I don't have my dukes anymore what yeah?
Looks at me a little like a hurt a little puppy. Sorry dude duty calls. I promise we'll catch up in a bit. Oh
He crying you're sweating. It's all good buddy
Sectarian runs off with his daughter and I'm left alone with mine, and I was really hoping to hang out craig more today
It seems like he's getting dragged in every direction. Definitely wasn't like this in college
Like me might be a third wheel here
Well his worst place is in an arcade to be left to your own devices
Right Wanna drop some corn on pinball. Did you know it man?
And I pull up to the machine that's feeling pretty hot and get to work
I'm a little rusty
But the pinball Wizard within me never died pull out a decent score, and then challenge Amanda to top mine and immediately again
She gets a multi ball. So she takes after her father pretty good. Oh patronize me
Hey, just trying to pay a comment Amanda stresses me. She's in her zen zone.
She fights valiantly ranking up points by the millions just close to beating my score
But if you want to just be able to watch your friends with Craig's right?
And from earlier walks up and leans on the pinball machine
Yeah, we went to college
Don't lean on my thing. Huh, that's so interesting. So do you know if he's like available? Honestly don't know if I could say
Seriously, you're gonna make it tilt because it just seems like you're so much work to watch after his kids
Don't even go to be great. If he
Lady I swear to God all the sudden other sounds in the game is over Danny made the pinball machine tilt
You still know?
What I said, I have to go over there now, and what weeds in my mouth
So I don't say anything that'll hurt your feelings man. No, bro
What's going on? That's our chant. We don't get out here
We're stuck for the rest of night wrangle Amanda and say some quick divides with craig head out the pizza place finally
Amanda promises that she'll keep the couch warm for me and heads home
Hope we don't mind me bringing you back here bro. Not at all dude
Good to finally get you all to myself for a second river burps. Well almost all of myself hold up. Oh
so cute
Wreck walked over to the drunken scar and pulled out two gloves in a sophomore
Oh for some catch this might be left catching more you thrown the ball and me running after it, but shirk
Standing in the middle of the empty baseball diamond and start tossing the ball back and forth
I have a cooler in my car that we could grab but there's only juice boxes in there, man father
It is strange nice. Tell me I can't believe I'm looking back in my kegstand days and reminiscing about it
Those are some of the good times. I don't know anyone else you could pull off the rare horizontal, Keg stand
There's a fee to discipline bro. Trust me. I haven't properly hung out with Craig and so long
I didn't even know where to begin oh
man
That's about the kids can't believe you're a father of three mom neither. Can I you know me
I'm an indecisive person switch your major four times. Yeah, I have no idea what I wanted to do with my life, but raising kids
Iron Hazel was born it. Finally all made sense. It was like all the time
I've been trying to figure out things led to them couldn't be happier about it
I don't think I ever cared about anything as much as I care about them
And the exact same feeling when a man who was born was the best thing to ever happen to me
it could be the only thing that ever happened to me and I would still be proud of the life I lived a
Softball coach life you wanted or was it the life that was thrust upon him
I'll admit that I was hesitant at first Briar and hazel had so much energy that we just had to get them in this
But no one was there to run the team the more I did it the more
I saw how much meant to all the girls I'm worried
There'd be a riot if we quit. I would also be afraid of a bunch of tiny children with metal bats
They're quick, and they work as a team. I've trained them too. Well it takes you down like a pack of velociraptors on T-Rex
exactly
Ask about the business you run a business out dude dude
Yeah, we sell fitness gear imports and exports mostly, but we're coming up with our own line of this. We'll use your where soon
I nod
Athleisure wear that sounds too PC. I want that so badly
I mostly use my sweatpants for watching TV
And whatnot you know sweating sounds like you'd make a killing if you ever need athletic gear I got your back
You could sponsor me. I'll rep your athleisure wear brand while I mow my lawn. That is the glamorous lifestyle. We're catering to yeah
Nice out here quiet
Good to get away from the softball moms for a bit. I don't know Christ Janet
Yeah knows a lot are they always like that actually this wasn't nearly as bad guys
I'm just so not interested. Well. What are you interested in?
Peace and quiet that hot hot sun night my ultimate sexual fantasy is sleeping in on a Saturday more seriously
I just can't get back into dating right now. I couldn't even if I wanted to there's
No time I feel so uncomfortable trying to introduce a stranger into my girls lives you've already been through so much I can't put them
Through that buddy
I hear ya, so the moms can hit on me all they want, but the girls are my top priority see hey
The right person will come along eventually
Maybe he's already here. You don't have to rub whoa. That was a lot eggplants Gonna
Have to raj it man things will fall into place for you something you're gonna find someone who cares about your kids just as much
As they care about you oh, bro. Yes, so sweet. Well, I'm distracted. I miss a softball oh
Fuck Brian
Wow, that hurts man. It was right all along. Sorry dude craig runs over to me. Oh you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine. Wait. Let me do the dad thing for a second greg spends a moment examining my head
It's worse than I thought don't tell me you have to kiss it and make it feel better
You would be so lucky
I
mean
Feel like I've earned it at this point waiting all day to hang out with you. Oh, well ah
River is not too. Happy about the fell water hey come on man
or girl greg leans in and kids my board walk it off champ the lights on the softball field really hot or is that just
Me I get up and dust myself off river yawns. Hey little buddy. You must be getting tired, huh?
Hey save, but I should probably head out all right things are so
You get older and life just kind of gets in the way, huh?
Start walking back to the parking lot and remember that one-ounce party we went to that got broken up by the helicopter
Dude you and me hopped over a concrete wall to get away
The other side of the fence with the parking lot where a bunch of cops were parked oh
Man, yeah, do you imagine the look on our faces?
We just walk straight past them like we were out for a stroll
Now knowing that we were at the party be sure joking with us about how big a bust it was I had to talk with
Him for 30 minutes you told them you're interested enjoying the academy and they started giving me pointers for the exam
long Sturdy minutes of my life man
golly good Old days
Right I get back to our cars greg pulls me in for a hug or at least
As much as we can manage with a baby between us never enough time, huh guess not oh
Let me make it up to you. Let's hang soon. Yeah, like oh
Greg oh, God well
I mean love yawn as I walked through the door spotting a man hunched over collage
Glue sticking and burning the midnight our don figured I might do something productive between episodes of Shark Hunter and lip-sync battles
The Shark lips anchored to the Shark Hunter slips off. Yes. Look over our shoulder at the collage man
It is some good art that is good art you made what good art that's great art. Thanks. I'm just about done
Look for it still a lot of dogs and one corner has a giant pile of cash and the other its
Man does that mean yep the whole thing is about my goals for the future
And those are basically just to sit on a giant pile of money with my 20 dogs and also have a strong and mutually supportive
Relationship with my father into adulthood. Oh now you've done it. You're ready to watch your dad grow here good. What's happening?
Dad you did it you take this with your good art is your fault. She passed me on the back
Hey, how was your hanging with Craig? I whup a tear for my eye
I went 17 tears for my it was good a craig guy sure is busy
Yeah, dude. The softball light isn't for quitters. Well. I'm very proud of you for facing up yours today. How's it feel?
Well top of the world pops which start facing my fears more often yeah come on tomorrow
We had some empty parking lots and practice dare I say
Parallel parking baby steps man. I'll work my way up to it alright
I might hit the hay take care of the late night television for me alright. Let them know you said hi, oh
That every dog exactly at every dog
please yeah, ah
So many points I got it for sure what?
What I think it s is a great car. Oh, yeah
Well, yes, that's a good place to end this on let's see what the next screen is though
Peter well actually has a phd in history. Oh man anyway. Yeah, oh to save this. Oh, that's good. So anyway
We just had our first successful date with Craig
And there's gonna be a lot of dating going on if I have to go through everybody like this, but either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching. I'm gonna keep playing this in the near future
I'm gonna finish this I don't know about 100% but I'm gonna finish this game
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know what you think down the comments below and let me know if you play this for yourself
Thanks again, and as always. I will see you in the next video. Bye. Bye